oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
story mode now there are challenge modes
left to play in this game there's also
the newspaper clippings but I don't know
what that leads to I don't know if it
leads to a true ending of this game but
there are these various challenge modes
now bedroom blind mode I want to take a
look at bender blind mode because I'm
pretty sure it's exactly what I think
it'll be you're gonna be blind and it's
probably very similar to the five nights
at freddy's for blind
oh there's the curtains oh boy good I've
got the curtains this is so ridiculous
oh you are supposed to hit the light how
are you gonna get bad and I've lost it
again I've lost it already what you guys
better just come on and kill me because
I have no idea what I'm doing so how
about you all go fall be yourself into
death cuz I there's no way how would you
do this I mean there's a way I could do
it if I really tried but I'm that wasn't
my intention here so just kill me right
now oh don't give me funny no oh
okay I think that's a challenge for
another day the other ones are basement
run mode and survival mode now basement
run that would take some trial and error
to get that done but I think that's
possible I think I can do that one so
I'm going to give that one a go eight
minutes is not a lot of time but I think
I can do basement run mode before I
could do blind mode now I don't even
know if I want to bash my head against
blind mode but and then again I don't
this one because I don't entirely
remember all the steps necessary to get
it done but I'll do my best
oh boy here we go alright skadoosh
skadoosh let's go let's go let's do is I
don't know what I'm doing
Skoosh Skoosh Skoosh okay here we go
the clock is started ooh fun I don't
want the way to look at you go okay
there we go
there's no running on this one so you
got to cut corners as best you can
well skadoosh key we come from the fire
or sure you do okay big boy whoa
parallel got that already stuff that in
my hand call me Sally okay you okay
alright look at this one Hey okay
alright not bad okay that worked out
pretty well so maybe we can just grab
the the last one I mean really that's it
right that's it
oh you wow whatever you're not that big
a deal I mean that's it right that's all
I gotta do right
okay ah how well is my first try so
let's give it another go I was close so
I don't know if I have done everything
right but that's gotta be it right and
then from there on it's not too bad no
it's possible
that's everything I think so it's just
carry on with round one oh god I don't
remember the codes okay it was nine
three uh it was nine six three two yeah
okay and that up where's this guy oh
he's gonna up here that's right
you stay right there oh boy wait did
something something I couldn't remember
if something was gonna happen in the
lights we're gonna go out and then you
were gonna get me but I was not sure
okay Bonnie's for Fred's three Foxy's
one uh yeah okay yeah okay one but no
not then okay one [ __ ] no that's wrong
chica was one [ __ ] god damn it oh [ __ ]
oh that's not good oh [ __ ] God way whoa
you watch that hand bro watch that hand
maybe I can lock this guy into because I
forgot that that was actually a thing I
could do get through get through okay
cool well that makes life easier but not
what I needed to do it was chica one
chica was one chica foxy Freddy Bonnie
yeah chica foxy Freddy Freddy Bonnie
okay then the key come on right there
it's right there got it oh you might not
want to close that one because then it
has to open again and then you're gonna
be stuck there yeah okay cool all right
good to know good to know good to know
good to know then you just keep going
right this is forward
there's forward and no looking back why
would I look back I've got three minutes
and 30 seconds to not look back why
would I do that
yeah this is a goddamn time sink right
here god this takes forever
incoming yeah 220 I don't think that's
gonna be enough time yeah now gonna be
enough time cuz I think you don't you
have to wait for them to stop talking so
that the doors open
yeah you gotta wait that's right you
gotta wait
ah [ __ ] yeah okay so they're gonna open
if you could just bolt it did you just
build it no
that
they're gonna get you yeah if you guys
could stay on the same side that
actually be really helpful if I remember
counter Wampus counter won't be don't
want beat and then hit this bad boy
that'll open that bad boy okay
got this guy oh god that's so scary oh
that's so scary
oh yeah oh no I just need to go up
that's right just need to go up tag yeah
okay so not enough time not enough time
but close though close and I know what
I'm gonna do next time is I'm going to
get the code and then I'm gonna flub
something else cuz that's just how I
roll I'm gonna be right there I'm gonna
be right there god damn it I'm gonna be
so close Scott dammit I am our name ah
now seconds away literally a second away
I was a second away oh and that was with
me flooding the code [ __ ] no chica foxy
Freddy Bonnie chica foxy Freddy Bonnie
chica foxy Freddy Bonnie chica foxy
chica foxy Freddy Bonnie that should be
more than enough space yeah fun quick
okay chica foxy Freddy Bonnie whoa okay
yep got it
nailed it okay you gone okay cool
alright we're good Oh convenient you can
Skoosh him over to one side
oh that's
okay that's your space there you go
right off I go one dude is right there
[ __ ] off with that oh [ __ ] you
are you kidding me with that [ __ ]
you know I'm gonna get myself a little
more room I'll never actually bring him
over because I don't need to be in that
much of a hurry come on you bastards
oh you're you stuck God you can't even
get through the door you guys try to get
me at the same time you just killed some
time a mine I don't like that very much
Oh like that all like this I've got you
okay so I just need to look at this guy
keep these guys in my line of sight and
then this guy will be fine there he is
thirties there is that so far
as far as you need to go Billy go whoa
hey hey whoa that was a close one wasn't
it oh that was close I don't like how
close that was oh boy oh boy my big boy
price huh God you little bastards Oh
buddy search think you can dick with me
the answer is mad be mad bad you could
dick with ya
doodlee do easy-peasy all done z1 Donny
Donny and almost a minute left to go eh
whoa whee so not bad not bad not bad I
bet there's people that have done it
faster than that but I was close on my
first try on my first try I was almost
there was almost there on my first ride
back second try sir pink slip nose if
you win don't come back effective now
did you employ two five for one
delusional accusations damage to company
property
odor why did you do it did you have
something to prove help the reward was
worth it xoxo have no idea is that the
same slip is like from one of the other
games no idea okay so anyway that was
basement run mode not bad I have a funny
feeling that's gonna be more interesting
to watch than blind mode because blind
mode is this gonna be me staring at a
black screen not talking cuz I'm trying
to listen so badly I don't know God you
just have to be facing the window and
the lamp and you'd have to get an idea
of where that was in relation to it each
other like the whole time but again not
like the lamp make makes noise so that's
gonna be hard but either way if you guys
know if the newspaper clippings are
worth it let me know because I want to
know if there's just a little something
more there and it seems like there might
be so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]